[Music]
with the arrival of the new year a lot
of things are changing in the movie
industry
probably the biggest and most recent
change being wanna brother's concept of
releasing all of the year's theatrical
films simultaneously in theaters
and on its hbo max platform there has
been criticism from many corners in this
regard including from star director
christopher nolan himself
this certainly won't change anything and
so the movie giant has just released a
small hbo max teaser with
all the highlights to fuel the fan's
anticipation
one of the highlights is a short clip
from godzilla vs kong that really
packs a punch you can see godzilla
coming threadly out of the sea and king
kong giving him a direct punch
after that this scene is already over in
terms of content the teaser ties
directly into the video footage released
a few weeks ago in which godzilla swims
under the surface of the sea
and kong stands on land and roars
there's also more news for fans of the
monster vs blockbuster
and that is at the release date in the
u.s is to be moved up by two whole
months to march 26th
whether this will be the case in other
parts of the world is presently unknown
what is certain however is that tomorrow
sunday january 24th the first
full-length trailer will finally be
released
so if you don't want to miss out on that
subscribe to our channel and
activate the notifications now as
netflix already announced via twitter in
october it's not holding back with
concentrated celebrity powerful don't
look up
the cast includes leonardo dicaprio
jennifer lawrence meryl streep
kate blanchet jonah hill and music stars
kid cootie and
ariana grande the big short director
adam mckay who is known for his special
humor anyway
stages a kind of dark humor sci-fi
comedy around the imminent impact of a
giant asteroid
however no one except for two space
explorers are aware of it and warning
all of humanity of the great disaster is
not so easy since the two are
anything but big shots in their field in
order to make themselves heard the duo
probably starts a media effective world
tour in order to warn the population
details on when don't look up will be
released on netflix are
not yet available pixar's latest film
luca is said to hit theaters in june
the first images which were released a
few days ago are definitely looking
pretty fancy and you get quite excited
about summer con
wise luca is about a little boy who's
about to have a long summer full of
beaches
ice cream and pasta naturally he doesn't
enjoy it all alone
as he is with his new best friend
alberto however
the two share a big secret as they
actually come from a far away
underwater world and are in fact quite
unattractive sea monsters as soon as
they enter the water
on land however they're
indistinguishable from normal humans
and so they try to make friends with
human girls over the summer
whether this succeeds so easily is of
course doubtful
in any case we are eager to see the next
coming-of-age film produced by pixar
luca hits theaters on june 18th 2021
just in time for the start of the movie
year 2021
wanna brothers is also providing us with
new video footage of the second part of
the iconic
space jam franchise while in the
original 1996 basketball superstar
michael jordan was still in front of the
camera together with nba co-stars and
looney tunes characters
lebron james will now assume this role
directing the film is girl script
director malcolm dealey after a lengthy
development period while the script was
written by black panther creators ryan
coogler
and seth o'hansen the release date for
space jam
a new legacy is july 16 2021 in theaters
and on hbo max until now there was
hardly any information about the video
game adaption mortal combat however as
the side bloody disgusting reported a
few days ago unofficial synopsis of the
plot is
now available the central character of
mortal kombat is supposed to be the mma
fighter called
young ever since he was born he has been
wearing some kind of dragon symbol on
his skin
which eventually leads to an attack by
sub-zero cole who is increasingly
worried about himself and his family's
safety
seeks out the soldier jax who's also
bearing a dragon symbol
eventually he gets to lord creighton's
temple via detours where he prepares for
his biggest fight
yet against outworld as fans of the
video games have surely noticed cole
young is a completely new character
introduced into the mortal kombat
universe which supports the rumors that
the movie will only be loosely based on
the games
in the recently released preview images
you can get a good idea of what's to
come
including the main character cole
sub-zero jax
kaino and zhonya blade the exact look of
greg russos and dave callahan's adoption
can be seen on hbo max
and in theaters starting april 16th 2021
also among the many weekly movies coming
to netflix is a horror film from justice
league director zack snyder
army of the dead the film features dave
potiza
and is set within the near future in the
gambling metropolis of las vegas
which is under quarantine the focus is
on a mercenary team that senses the big
money in the closed off city as you can
already see within a few seconds of the
big netflix preview of 2021
in addition there are already a number
of images you can have a look at such as
behind the scenes footage as well as the
core of the cast in an interview with
entertainment weekly snyder has also
talked about the overall use of his
horror film saying that viewers will
also be surprised by soothing moods
in between the crazy heist scenes as if
that wasn't enough
snyder has also ordered a prequel series
directed by matthias schweikerffer as
well as an anime series called
army of the dead las vegas so the focus
of the netflix blockbuster is clearly
towards the franchise
it is not clear yet when exactly army of
the dead will be released for netflix
the year 2020 was a complete success
from a business perspective
not very surprising after all rarely
have so many people around the globe
been forced to sit at home in front of
the screen
well the new year is already in full
swing and netflix isn't even thinking
about
shifting down a gear recently the
responsible parties released a small
teaser in which one of the highlights
was certainly
red notice with gal gadot dwayne johnson
and ryan reynolds
the content is about an interpol agent
who works with an impostor to catch a
genius art thief
a first look is also provided in the
netflix preview video for 2021
where you can gaze at a few funny
moments and a highly
explosive situation an interesting story
paired with one of the most high profile
casts
imaginable at the moment what more could
you ask for
[Music]